let's go next to our caller from the
five-one-six-- area code who's calling
today from five one six hello David
servants hey sorry what was your name
Ervin's Ervin's okay what's going on hey
I have a question about the presidency
and the terms that they are a lot sir
okay right so when Donald Trump took
office right he did a lot of he undid a
lot of Barack Obama's things right so
now hopefully in 2020 if let's say a
Bernie Sanders was to win the election
and he served two terms don't you think
another Republican president could come
in and undo a majority of things that he
would implement I mean sure depends what
things I mean this is a problem in
American politics which is that a lot of
the actions that presidents take via
executive order can be undone can you
undo the damage that they do not always
but you can change course yeah this is a
problem and you know listen to a certain
degree this is kind of how it works
right when someone wins elections have
consequences and they can make changes
the problem is when someone comes in
like Trump and gets out of the Iran deal
without Iran having violated the terms
that's really problematic I don't have a
problem I mean to some degree it's like
politics or politics and when the new
person comes in they get to make
decisions they might be different
decisions than the last person the
problem is when the last person makes a
deal with Iran and Iran sticks to it and
Trump still bails then it's a problem
for the credibility of the US because
why would other countries get into
agreements when they have no confidence
the next person will stick to it so it's
what you're mentioning is a concern
sometimes but it's also politics so
would you be in favor of I guess
abolishing a president can only serve
two terms and lens serve multiple no I
wouldn't why would why would that be the
solution no well for the simple reason
if we have a president inside the Oval
Office and who we're we're trustworthy
of and who was leading
America down the right path aren't you
fearful that somebody else who isn't as
qualified as the person who was in there
and the president at the time would have
been able to build a lot of
relationships and then out of nowhere
after eight years boom poof another
person is in well it's not nowhere it's
how our system has worked for a really
long time and I think your argument
applies to the other side do you want
someone who's a disaster but is able to
convince enough people to vote for them
do you want them to be able to be in
there twelve sixteen or twenty years I
mean there's two sides to that coin and
I think that the path forward is is not
to get rid of term limits that's a
terrible terrible idea
alright Arvin's thanks for the call
appreciate it
um just uh just disagree politely
disagree with you